LIGHTER TOPIC OF THE EVENING.
WHAT DOES THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES HAVE FOR DESSERT?
JEANNE MOOSE HAS AN
INVESTIGATION.
>> Reporter: "TIME" MAGAZINE GOT
A SCOOP, LITERALLY A SCOOP.
>> ONE SCOOP FOR ME, PLEASE.
>> Reporter: ON THE PRESIDENT'S
SCOOP WE ALREADY KNEW HE HANKERS
FOR TACO BOWLS AND BIG MACS AND
KFC EATEN WITH A KNIFE AND FORK
AND SOMETIMES INSISTS ON FELLOW
DINERS EATING MEATLOAF.
>> THEN HE SAY, CHRIS, YOU AN I
WILL HAVE THE MEATLOAF.
>> IT'S EMASCULATING.
>> NO, IT'S NOT.
>> WE'VE HEARD IMDESCRIBE THAT
U.S. LAUNCHES AGAINST SYRIA.
>> WE HAD THE MOST BEAUTIFUL
PASS OF CHOCOLATE CAKE YOU'VE
OVER SEEN.
>> WHICH BRINGS US TO ICE CREAM.
>> NOW IN THE BLUE ROOM OF THE
WHITE HOUSE, THE PRESIDENT SITS
DOWN FOR DINNER WITH THREE
CONTEMPORARIES FROM "TIME"
MAGAZINE, DINING WITH THE
ENEMIES OF THE PEOPLE, OF COURSE
THEY WILL NOTICE EVERY LITTLE
THING.
>> WITH THE SALAD COURSE, TRUMP
IS SERVED WHAT APPEARS TO BE
THOUSAND ISLAND DRESSING INSTEAD
OF CREAMY VINEGAR RET FOR
GUESTS.
AT THE DESSERT COURSE HE GETS
TWO SCOOPS OF VANILLA ICE CREAM
WITH HIS CHOCOLATE CREAM PIE
INSTEAD OF THE SINGLE SCOOP FOR
EVERYONE ELSE.
>> TWO SCOOPS FOR ME PLEASE ♪
>> SO THE WHOLE DOMINANCE THING
EXTENDS TO DESSERTS, TOO?
JOE BIDEN HAS SPOKEN AS IF HE
WERE A MEMBER OF ICE CREAM
ADDICTS ANONYMOUS.
>> MY NAME IS JOE AND I LOVE ICE
CREAM.
>> Reporter: HE DOESN'T HAVE ONE
NAMED FOR HIM IN TRUMP TOWER.
CHECK OUT THIS.
NOT A REAL ONE, JUST A SPOOF.
PRESIDENT OBAMA GOT THE SAME
IMPEACH MINT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S FACE HAS BEEN
PLASTERED ON ICE CREAM.
MAYBE HE SHOULD INVITE THIS
ITALIAN CHAMPION TO THE WHITE
HOUSE.
HE HOLDS THE GUINNESS RECORD FOR
THE MOST SCOOPS BALANCED ON A
CONE, 121.
THAT IS A TALL CONE TO CLIMB,